العسكري باسم كتائب سرايا القدس الجناح
العسكري للجهاد الاسلامي
صلى الله
على ما بعد
يا جماهير بن الصامد المقاوم
يا عشاق المقاومه وانصارها في كل مكان
تحيه المجاهدين الصامدين الصابرين لكم
فالسلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته
كعادته الدمويه
ارتكب العدو فجر اليوم
بكل صلف واجحاف جريمه جديده
بحق شعبنا وقادتنا ومجاهدينا
في مجازر مروعه ومتفرقه في مناطق مختلفه
في قطاع غزه
جريمه
يندى لها زبين الانسانيه
بحق الانسانيه والمدنيين
ظانا وواهما ان هذه الدماء ستكون جسرا
للعبور وطوقا للنجاه
اننا في سرايا القدس
نزف الى العلا ثله مقدامه من قادتنا
وشعبنا ومقاومنا
ارتقوا خلال عمليه اغتيال جبانه فجر اليوم
وهم
الشهيد القائد الكبير
جهاد شاكر الغنام
امين سر المجلس العسكري في سرايا القدس
والشهيد القائد الكبير خليل صلاح البهتيني
عضو المجلس العسكري
وقائد المنطقه الشماليه في سرايا القدس
والشهيد القائد الكبير طارق ابراهيم عز
الدين
احد قاده العمل العسكري في سرايا القدس في
الضفه المحتله
اننا ونحن نزف شهدائنا القاده العظام
الذين ذاق العدو وجنرالاته باسهم الشديد
عبر عشرات السنين
ومعهم
كوكبه طاهره من زوجاتهم وابنائهم وابناء
شعبنا المجاهد البطل
نؤكد ان هذه الجريمه الاثمه
لن تزيدنا الا ايمانا بالله
وتسليما بقضائه
واصرارا على مواصله الطريق الذي سلكه
الشهداء
هذه الطريق
التي لن تكون نهايتها الا الهزيمه المؤكده
للعدو
وقادت اركانه
وسيكون وعد الله لنا بالنصر والتمكين ان
شاء الله
يا جماهير شعبنا الصابر المرابط
اننا امام هذا العدوان البربري الظالم
نؤكد في سرايا القدس والمقاومه على ما يلي
اولا
ندعو جماهير شعبنا الى الصبر والصمود
والالتفاف حول المقاومه
كخيار استراتيجي لردع المحتل وصد العدوان
على طريق التحرير والكرامه
فاحتسبوا الامكم وجراحكم عند الله
والصبر طليعه كل نصر بعون الله
ثانيا
ان هذه المجازر التي يرتكبها جيش الارهاب
الصهيوني
بحق المدنيين الابرياء في بيوتهم
ستزيد شعبنا الباسل
تمسكا بالمقاومه حتى تحرير فلسطين كل
فلسطين
ثالثا
نؤكد في سرايا القدس والمقاومه اننا سنكون
عند التزامنا وواجبنا تجاه الشهداء
وسنواجه العدوان بكل ثبات
واقدام بمشيئه الله وقوته
ختاما سيخلف القائد الف قائد
وسيحمل اللواء فرسان جدد
يواصلون الدرب حتى زوال هذا الكيان عن ارض
فلسطين الحبيبه الطاهره
وسيعلم الذين ظلموا اي منقلب ينقلبون
والسلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته